leute warten wir haben noch eine zugabe
haben wir noch was man unterschreibt du
mit geburt das ist so traurig alter
vergessen hat dem ich das video
freitreppe in dem ich leone macias 24
stunden im kino frame gegen die
kommentiert habt noch unterwegs bin dann
bin ich heute morgen aufgewacht dafür
sorgt das video läuft und dann habe ich
die kommentare sehen
und weil die kommentare
einigen fans noch von anderen leuten
unter dem letzten video grenzwertig war
noch nicht dazu genaueres sagen möchte
heute dieses video bevor es losgeht ich
hatte ihr beim letzten mal diesen iz
mail hintergrund auf einem der monitore
ich habe heute wieder andere
hintergründe und zwar einmal lebens
zuschauer original wollen wir zugesehen
habe ich mal so es wieder gepackt und
hier drücken meine reaktion dazu ich
mich in diesem fall gefühlt habe es gab
beim letzten auch einige kommentare zu
dem hintergrund wo leute wirklich meinen
es würde sie so krass trägern aber ich
hoffe das lag daran dass herr roth war
ich hoffe die hintergründe träge lang
heute nicht wenn doch sorry ich mag
einfach diese wiederum zu haben und
jetzt firma nun die schreibt sagt selber
dass sie die videos nur so nennen aber
nur vier fünf sechs sieben stunden trend
bleiben okay das ist ein punkt den sehr
viele gemacht haben erst mal ich schaue
nicht jedes video von liedermacher und
das ist auch gut so deswegen werde es
irgendwann der video gesagt hat konnte
ich das jetzt einfach nicht wissen
verstehe dass die channel so heißt und
dass man es halt rein schreibt damit
vier klicks bekommt aber aber der
kommentar war ungefähr mal gar nichts
denn darauf antwortet irgendein typ
dessen name ich jetzt mal nicht nenne
das folgende erste auftritte du nimmst
du so anderem futterproben blaue einfach
mal sieben richtigen dünnschiss weil die
saison kein feld für dein bild content
beispielsweise kunden aus dem bezugs
video bla bla bla bla bla erstmal was
fehlt dir eigentlich so anzureden du
verdammt drauf und dann natürlich das
argument billig content wenn man content
von leo maschinen apparate kritisiert
ich finde ich gesagt dass das der billy
konnte ist wenn ich bei video machen
indem ich deren kontext pause dann finde
ich das absolut berechtigt er schreibt
dann auch noch scheiß youtube besteht
nur noch aus rum packen weil andere eben
mehr erfolg haben als man selbst
und das ist so ein großes großes problem
jedes mal wenn man irgendjemanden
kritisiert auf youtube der mehr klicks
oder mehr abos als man selbst hat heißt
es aber es ist nur neid man will das
auch gerne haben und dieses argument ist
einfach so dumm selbstverständlich
passieren manchmal irgendwelche
reaktionen nicht sein sollten aus neid
absolut das komfort aber wenn leute
schlechten content machen dann ist es
doch jedermanns recht darauf aufmerksam
zu machen zum beispiel wenn helene
fischer schlechte musik macht und ich
finde die musik ist schlecht in welcher
welt leben wir denn wenn ich sage ich
finde die musik schlecht und die
kritisieren und dann kommt irgendwann
sagt
du bist doch nur neidisch auf helene
fischer textes nicht es ist einfach das
konzept von kritik wenn man leute
berechtigt kritisiert und dann kommen
irgendwelche deppen und schreiben was
von wegen
sneijder wird sich jede einzelne
gehirnzellen in meinem kopf umbringen
das ist so ein dummes atmen aber davon
abgesehen fand ich die nutzlose anregung
von atomen schon geil das ist schon geil
pops dafür der zocker schreibt ich habe
jedes von diesen vier stunden in videos
gemeldet gegen spam oder ihre führende
inhalte allein schon der titel ist
gelogen also völlig zurecht gemeldet das
war der jetzt sehr sehr viele likes
bekommen und dazu möchte ich mal sagen
leute ich hasse apa/red nicht ich hasse
leeren maschine auch nicht will dass
denkt der kann gerne weiter am leben
vorbei gehe aber so ist es auch nicht
ich habe recht persönlich auch schon mal
getroffen und ich fahren der war nicht
okay also ich habe keinen anlass ihn zu
hassen er macht nur teilweise einfach so
würde sachen dafür darf nur noch
kritisieren und in dem fall muss ich zu
seiner verteidigung sagen das ist zu
krass leute das ist so krass nur weil
dem titel 24 stunden steht und er dann
nicht tatsächlich 24 stunden im ding
drin es wegen ihrer fülle und inhalten
zu melden
das ist dass es zu krass leute also wir
müssen mit unserer kritik auch noch
vernünftig bleiben weil wir nämlich
aufhören leute zu kritisieren und
anfangen leute fertig zu machen dann
machen die selbst einfach nur noch alles
ab dann geht die kritiker uns nichts und
führt zu nichts also wir müssen
vernünftig und verhältnismäßig
kritisieren der nächste typ schreibt
junge du idiot hättest du mal das sex
video gesehen dann hättest du gemerkt
dass leon malaysia sagte wenn die 24
stunden reinschreiben versuchen wir so
lange wie möglich hier zu bleiben man
bist du ein lappen zuvor gesagt es bei
den 13 stunden 24 kinder ist kein satz
würde ich mal deine hässliche fresse ins
cup- stecken um ist geburt was ein
anfänger richtiger lappen okay leute das
was von meinem youtube-channel ich
stecke jetzt meine fresse ins grab
bis dann haut rein und dann leute so
wichtig ein lichtblick endlich mal ein
vernünftiger kommentar und zwar monse
schreibt jojo ich habe keinen plan war
um mich unterhalten die videos von maria
ich hab ich ja kein verboten dass wir
seine unterhalten vollkommen okay auch
wenn ich weiß dass folgt ist das mit den
zwei stunden schwach sind es halt für
klicks aber es waren ja nicht mal 13
stunden das waren vielleicht drei oder
vier oder so und ganz ehrlich was juckt
es mich nicht die strafgelder sie zahlen
müssen kein grund es nicht zu feuer oder
wenn jemand verteidigen aber ich denke
mal die leute die nike geben mich
eingeschlossen haben sich in welcher
hinsicht auch immer ab
okay du hast vollkommen recht mit einem
kommentar den kommentar ist wirklich gut
die aussage von mir dass ich mich für
jeden schäme deren live da gelassenheit
war zu krass das muss ich zurück nehmen
leute weil es gibt scheinbar auf jeden
fall auch vernünftige leute wie der
kommentar gezeigt hat die die videos
schauen und sicher denken wenn er sich
zum affen machen will und wenn eine
anzeige kassieren will wenn er was weiß
ich was eine geldstrafe bekommen will
den der straftat so was machen solange
ich unterhalten bin okay alles klar kann
ich akzeptieren so als nächstes schreibt
mercedes benz achtung caps lock aber
warum kaum die police fragezeichen
fragezeichen fragezeichen kopf hoch das
leben geht weiter
lieber mercedes benz ich weiß nicht wen
oder als profilbild hast es ist
offensichtlich kein mercedes benz warum
kann die police kamen die police
überhaupt ich habe an keiner stelle im
video die polizei gesehen habt ihr die
polizei gesehen vielleicht habe ich auch
irgendwann den augen und ich kann
einfach polizei nicht sehen aber soweit
ich weiß war hopp keine polizei in dem
video markus duma schreibt einen
kommentar der vielleicht als hater
kommentar gesehen werden könnte aber
trotzdem noch halbwegs ordentlich
formuliert ist und zwar du bist einer
meiner lieblings youtuber aber man muss
sich ja nicht in alle angelegenheiten
einmischen
ok vernünftig geschrieben dankeschön das
stimmt man muss sich tatsächlich nicht
in alle angelegenheiten einmischen und
ich mache das auch nicht mega oft also
wie viele videos habe ich gemacht wo ich
irgendwie content von anderen kritisiere
oder wo ich andere hätte jetzt andere
youtuber dieses belüfter machen ich bin
jetzt kein riesengroßer hater und ich
finde auch kanäle probe nicht die nur um
hält aufgebaut sind wie zum beispiel
kuchen tv auch wenn viele kugeln
vermögen ich finde halt so dieses mal
alles nun darum aufbaut ist halt so naja
gabriele für sich selbst entscheiden wie
die sagt markus du hast recht damit man
sollte sich nicht in alles einmischen
aber man sollte auf jeden fall seine
meinung äußern dürfen und kritik äußern
dürfen wenn sie berechtigt ist und in
dem fall finde ich war sie berechtigt
ganz ehrlich ich hab mich heutzutage das
gefühl dass einfach nur noch totale
hirnverbrannte content die startseite
dominiert und mit halbwegs normalen
contente nicht ausbaden 24 stunden in
oder sonstwas besteht hat man irgendwie
auf einmal sehr schwer auf youtube
deswegen glaube ich ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir als community die startseite
youtuber die teilweise bis in
fragwürdigen content machen an der
kurzen leine halten und wenn sie über
die stränge schlagen uns übertreiben sie
kritisieren das ist unsere aufgabe
dann leute eine sehr philosophische
weitere äußerung von tieto gaming pvp
das ist doch egal wer es vergessen hat
es egal ja es ist lustig erst mal
vielleicht ein bisschen länger machen
wird sich darüber lustig jeder macht mal
rechtschreibfehler manche mehr manche
weniger
scheiß drauf aber mein lieber tissot ich
finde persönlich ist nicht ändern möchte
nicht übertreiben und ich möchte ja
nicht so darstellen als welcher erlöser
von youtube und ich will alles wieder
gut machen oder so dass bullshit ich bin
genauso ein wahrer mensch wie alle
anderen operativ aber ich finde es zeit
nicht gesehen eine million leute ganz
ehrlich findet ihr es cool denn was das
fake ist weil ich als echt verkauft wird
ich persönlich fand es nicht gut
vielleicht gibt es andere dieser ein
gespräch oder nicht fällt mir doch egal
aber wir erinnern uns an was es für ein
riesen aufsteiger als die beziehung
zwischen dhabi und laien tau flog das
war fake da haben sich so viele
aufgeregt wir erinnern uns eines ganze
drama um nicht gekennzeichnete fordert
placement das ist fake man tut so als
wäre es kein bracelet obwohl setzt ist
also fake da gab es nur diesen theater
diebe auf 100 gameplay meinem vater von
merck matan experiment aber auch fade
als das herauskam gab es auch ein
riesenauftrag also warum sollten wir
dann bei fake videos auf einmal aufhören
ihr glaubt nicht wie viele youtuber sich
real life stories einfach ausdenken und
dann so tun als wäre die wirklich
passiert die denken sich die einfach aus
so viele machen das und die sitzt dann
glaubst du dass das echte leben ist das
ist halt schon irgendwo im cool mogelt
sehr gut schreibt ein hey nur weil du
keine eier hast um das nachzumachen
das haben wir so viele geschrieben dass
ich keine eier habe um das nachzumachen
was ist das für ein argument ich sehe
dass seine mentorin einfach nicht dass
es so als würde auf der straße
beobachten wie jemand jemand anderem was
cloud dass es auch eine straftat genau
wie hausfriedensbruch und dann sagt
irgendwann einmal hier habt ihr das
gesehen was geklauten das finde ich
falsch stelle ich vor der andere sagt
wollte ja nur weil du keine eier hatte
selbst was zu klauen das wieder so ein
moment von kopf will einfach explodieren
weil ich etwas kritisiere heißt das
nicht automatisch dass ich entweder
neidisch bin oder nicht selbst die eier
habe das zu machen das kann einfach
daran liegen dass es einfach dumm ist
der nächste kommentar ist wieder eine
große bereicherung für die menschheit
und zwar schreibt den ganzen sich mal
das ist eine challenge die opfer hashtag
dieser youtube ist ein opfer leute da
ist es besser weiß
es war eine change leute
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
der nächste schreibt du bist auch du die
haben gesagt wir bleiben 50 7 bis 8
schon drin aber die challenge 24 stunden
challenge tour jetzt doch nur um weil du
die kleinen eier der welt hast und du
dir ist nicht traust alter schwede
das ist wieder das gleiche argument mit
kleinsten eier also die leute die
zuschauer von ihren plätzen als sehr auf
ihn fixiert so gefühlt jeder zweite
kommentar irgendwas mit eiern zu tun
entweder meine eier sind nicht groß
genug oder ich hab keine ahnung ich weiß
nicht aber eier sind schon mal für sie
ein großes thema aber wenn wir mal
drüber nachdenken was er damit
eigentlich sagt ich habe nicht die eier
welches zutrauen was bedeutet das wenn
er denkt das ganze wäre quasi fake oder
gestellt und abgesprochen
dann brauchen wir ja gar keine haben das
zu machen wenn er sagt man braucht es zu
machen und ich habe nicht das wo es zu
machen dann geht er sich selbst davon
aus dass es eine straftat ist weil
raucher um abgesprochen ins kino
einzubrechen ich glaube nicht braucht
man um verbotenerweise ins kino
einzubrechen
vielleicht schon eher bei aller jetzt in
anführungszeichen gesetzt weil es
einfach dummes ins kino einzubrechen und
zu guter letzt klaus-peter mit like
alabaster alter ok like alabaster was
kann jetzt darauf antworten a genau wenn
wir mal die beiden videos vergleichen
also mein video und das video über das
ich geredet habe in welchem video wurde
nach likes auf ein youtube-video gebeten
weil ich mich erinnere ist in meinem
video das wort leicht nur gefeiert als
gesagt habe okay die wollte ich das
gelegt haben sind die bilder aber das
war eine dumme aussage von mir die nehme
ich auch zurück sorry dafür aber wenn
wir uns an das video von leo noch mal
erinnern wie war es mit light guide
250.000 auf dieses video 88.000 live
beide instagram bilder bin ich denn der
like geile oder etwa leute warten wir
haben doch alle eine zugabe haben wir
noch was man duo der schreibt du mit
geburt ist es so traurig alter mit
geburt ich bin einfach keine richtige
geburt sondern als es darum ging dass
ich auf die welt kommen soll an gott
einfach so gesagt ja der typ hat keine
eigene geburt verdient machen wir das
die vorder und noch platz oder
ok dann hat man dann auch dazu und dann
wurde ich da einfach mit geboren
so wird man mit geburt leute leben als
mit geburt ist nicht leicht das was von
diesem video habe mir einfach wichtig
mich nicht nur weil leute lustig zu
machen die mich kritisieren sondern auch
sinnvoll quasi ohne diskussionen
entstehen zu lassen und auch mal leuten
recht zu geben kritisieren weil man
konnte mich auf jeden fall ein paar
dinge kritisieren absolut was habt ihr
euch gedacht dass hier die kommentare in
diesem video gesehen habe schreibt mal
reaktion unten in die kommentare
und bis zum nächsten mal